so San Diego comic-con is this upcoming
weekend and there is going to be so much
happening I'm going to be covering
comic-con all throughout the weekend and
all throughout the week so be sure to
subscribe to my channel so you can stay
up to date on all the new info that we
get throughout comic-con one of the
biggest things that we're going to get
throughout comic-con is the Aquaman
trailer this is something that we've
been waiting for for a very long time
and many people actually thought that we
would get it sooner but it has been
confirmed that we are going to receive
it at comic-con in fact it has been
confirmed that this Saturday at Comic
Con will be the first time that it has
shown Aquaman director James Wan took to
social media last night to share a sneak
peek of the Aquaman trailer stating that
he is working overtime to put the
finishing touches on the trailer so this
weekend is going to be super exciting
Aquaman is the first movie to come out
in the DC EU after Justice League and
hopefully this will be a great movie and
we'll start to revamp the DC EU those
who have seen pieces of it say that it
looks amazing we also got the first
official theatrical poster for the movie
today the poster shows our hero
underneath the sea in Atlantis
surrounded by a bunch of different
sharks and killer whales and a ton of
marine life with the tagline home is
calling this movie already seems
different than other DC movies and a big
thing is that it said that the animation
is going to be a lot better to me this
is something that DC has really lagged
behind Marvel in I can already tell from
the posters that we've seen and from the
official looks that we've gotten from
Entertainment Weekly all the photos that
came out then it's a lot brighter it's a
lot more vibrant and to me that
automatically is going to make it better
I've heard that they've really put a lot
of time and effort into making this
movie great so I really hope that's the
case again we get the first look at this
trailer on Saturday so be sure to
subscribe to my channel so you can get
all the new information that comes out
hit me with your thoughts from the
screenshot of the trailer that we
received and the new poster that we've
as well hit me with your thoughts in the
comments below and be sure to like this
video before you head out thank you all
so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
you